Sexting is all the rage.
And which age group
is doing it the most?
Teenagers.
Hey everyone.
Laci Green here for D News.
I have a funny feeling
that parents are slowly
beginning to realize
that sexting should
be on the list of things
that are discussed
with their teenagers.
Recently, the massive
Snapchat hacking,
which exposed personal
data of most of its users,
got a lot of people talking
about sexting and privacy.
And now the Journal
of Pediatrics
published a new
study which found
that 20% of seventh
graders are sexting.
Now before your
jaw drops too far,
the study sample
was seventh graders
who were identified by
their school counselor
as already having some emotional
or behavioral difficulties.
And of those in the study group,
those who were sexting were
more likely to make out and
have sex than those who didn't.
Shocker.
I know.
Just so we're all
on the same page,
legally sexting refers
to sexual photo, video,
and text messages sent
using a cell phone.
The National Campaign found
that across the board about 40%
of teens have sent sexually
suggestive messages.
A quarter of high schoolers
and a third of college students
admit to having sent and
received nude pictures.
Sending text sex was more
common amongst young men,
while sending nude
or semi-nude photos
was more common amongst women.
And 61% of the
women said that they
felt pressured to
send the pictures.
So this makes me
wonder, why is sexting
so common amongst teens?
It's unfortunate that
a huge part of it
is feeling pressured.
Being a teenager is full of
all kinds of sexual pressures,
so I suppose sexting is just a
modern addition to that list.
Another big part of
it is that, well, they
think it's fun and sexy.
Another huge shocker.
When I was a
rambunctious youngen,
I also remember
feeling like sexting
was less intimidating
than in-person flirting.
The phone made the
exchange kind of abstract.
It was less awkward.
And it felt like there
were fewer consequences.
Text sex won't get you
pregnant or give you an STI,
but my teens
proceeded picture sex,
which are a whole
other can of worms.
On their own, they
won't get you pregnant,
usually, but about
one in five sextors
admit to sharing the
photos they receive
with a friend or two or three.
This suggests that
teens aren't being
taught the importance of
respecting their partner's
privacy.
Another study found
that a third of teens
didn't think about the
legal ramifications.
Situations where it's
considered child pornography
and could get them
labeled as sex offender.
Yeah, the laws are
stupidly behind.
So what's to be done?
We live in a high-tech,
hyper-sexualized world.
Sexting isn't going away.
And thus, experts advise that
it needs to be discussed early.
Kids as young as
11 have admitted
to sexting unbeknownst
to their parents.
And the conversations about sex
tend to focus on don't do it.
Just don't do it.
But this is an
adequate preparation.
Teens need to
understand that it's
under no circumstances OK to
pressure someone into sexting.
Nor is it OK to share
someone's photos.
And both of these
behaviors are disrespectful
and increasingly illegal.
Teens also need to be
informed about what
the risks of sexting
actually are.
How to be safe.
To understand
harm-reducing alternatives.
And how to navigate situations
where they're being pressured.
All of this starts
with open, gentle,
and non-confrontational
conversations with teens.
Perhaps asking what
they know about sexting
and what they think
about it, to start.
So what do you guys
think about sexting?
Share your thoughts down below,
and I'll catch you next time.